I'm retiring Giselle reacted to Tom's
retirement with support but others not
so much what would it be like to be
Gisele today okay so you could have
saved the marriage a year ago when I
begged you to do this and you refused
and you decided for 300 plus days it
would be worth it to lose me what a
middle finger no maybe there's a 80 for
Brady sequel coming out look he said it
he
is let's go next for the seven time
Super Bowl champ well he does have a 375
million dollar analyst deal with Fox
Sports but ETS learned his main priority
is spending time with his children he's
not going to rush back into work or
dating but speaking of the big game when
they asked you to perform your reaction
was you know you have those that moment
of like what
me yes yes it was an immediate yes I sat
down exclusively with Abbott Elementary
Cheryl Lee Ralph who will perform lift
every voice and sing which has been part
of the last few Super Bowls
and Rihanna's there what they would not
have chosen me if they did not feel I
could deliver and I'm ready to deliver I
don't get
sweetheart neither do I is it especially
sweet for you since Billy is there my
husband you know he's a senator in
Philadelphia and he was out in the
community giving away Eagles gears and
shirt he said we're in it to win it and
I was like yes bye Eagles well next
Sunday the Kelsey family will be split
as Jason and Travis become the first
Brothers to go head to head our mom and
dad sitting on your sideline are they
sitting on my sideline
dude we do have to figure that out many
actually want their mom Donna on the
field thousands have signed to
change.org petition to get her to do the
coin toss oh and since Jason's wife
Kylie is expecting daughter number three
she has a very important Super Bowl
guest Kylie's bringing her OB because
she's gonna be 38 weeks pregnant dude
dude if she has a baby in the stadium
it's officially scripted on their
podcast New Heights the eagle Center and
the Chiefs tight end reflected on the
big game's other big first two black
quarterbacks facing off and two former
childhood teammates AJ Brown Willie Gay
Jr yeah played high school ball together
I kind of don't like that we're calling
it The Kelsey bull kind of appreciate
the support there's a lot of guys
involved with this
foreign